EARLY VOTING IN GEORGIA'S SENATE
RUNOFF BETEN THE DEMOCRATIC
INCUMBENT RAPHAEL WARNOCK AND
HIS REPUBLICAN CHALLENGER
HERSCHEL WALKER.
SO FAR, RECORD EARLY TURNOUT AND
EYE-POPPING SPENDING BY BOTH
PARTIES.
OUR NEW CNN POLL RELEASED TODAY
SHOWS SENATOR WARNOCK WITH A
SMALL LEAD.
DEMOCRATS WILL CONTROL THE
SENATE NOW NO MATTER WHO WINS ON
TUESDAY, BUT AS BOTH CANDIDATES
GET SOME HIGH-POWERED HELP IN
THE FINAL DAYS, BOTH SIDES
PUBLICLY ACKNOWLEDGE HAVING 51
DEMOCRATS INSTEAD OF 50 MAKES A
BIGGER DIFFERENCE THAN YOU MIGHT
IMAGINE.
>> AN EXTRA SENATOR GIVES
DEMOCRATS MORE BREATHING ROOM ON
IMPORTANT BILLS.
IT PREVENTS ONE PERSON FROM
HOLDING UP EVERYTHING.
AND IT ALSO PUTS US IN A BETTER
POSITION A COUPLE YEARS FROM
NOW.
>> IF IT'S 50/50, THE BUDGETS
ARE THE SAME.
THE NUMBER OF COMMITTEE PEOPLE
IS THE SAME.
IF IT'S 51-49, THEY HAVE ONE
MORE VOTE ON EVERY COMMITTEE
THAN US.
THE BOTTOM LINE, IT REALLY
CHANGES THE STRUCTURE OF THE
SENATE.
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM AND
BARACK OBAMA, I SAW THE NODDING,
SOME NODDING, SOME IS THSHRUGGI.
IT'S HUGELY DIFFERENT.
51-50, YOU THINK WHAT IS THE BIG
DEAL?
IT DOES IN TERMS OF SUBPOENA
POWER, COMMITTEE HEARINGS.
>> YEAH, LOOK, BECAUSE THERE'S A
DIVIDED GOVERNMENT, IT PROBABLY
WOULD NOT HAVE AS MUCH IMPACT AS
IF IT WERE ONE PARTY
CONTROLLING.
ONE PARTY CONTROL, THEY PASSED
THE BUDGET PROCESS WHICH COULD
CIRCUMVENT A FILIBUSTER IN THE
SENATE AND COULD PASS BILLS
ALONG STRAIGHT PARTY LINES WHICH
IS WHY JOE MANCHIN HAD SO MUCH
POWER.
HE TRIED TO DO EVERYTHING AND
THOSE BIG BILLS, NO, IT WASN'T
GOING TO HAPPEN.
GET THE ADDITIONAL SENATOR, THAT
HELPS AND THE NEW CONGRESS YOU
HAVE A REPUBLICAN HOUSE, A
DEMOCRATIC SENATE SO VERY LITTLE
WILL GET ACCOMPLISHED ANYWAYS.
YES, IT WILL CHANGE SOME OF THE
COMMITTEE STRUCTURE.
YOU MAY HAVE ONE MORE SEAT
MARGIN THAN YOU DO AS A
DEADLOCKED SENATE BUT WAYS TO
GET AROUND THAT.
AS HUGE OF AN IMPACT AS THEY'RE
SAYING, EVERY VOTE COUNTS AND WE
GET INTO FUTURE ELECTION CYCLES
WHEN THEY WILL BATTLE ONE OR TWO
SEATS TO TAKE THE MAJORITY AN
ADDITIONAL SEAT WILL BE CRUCIAL.
>> EVERY VOTE COUNTS SO IT'S
ENCOURAGING WHETHER DEMOCRAT OR
REPUBLICAN TO SEE THE RECORD
EARLY VOTING AND LONG LINES
WHERE EVA WHAT, LARGELY
DEMOCRATIC BUT WE'VE SEEN LARGE
EARLY VOTING IN OTHER PARTS OF
THE STATE AS WELL WHERE YOU HAVE
MORE REPUBLICAN VOTERS.
THE LATEST POLL, 52% FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC INCUMBENT AND 48% FOR
HERSCHEL WALKER.
IF YOU DIG DEEP, THIS IS
INTERESTING TO ME.
DO YOU VIEW THESE CANDIDATES AS
FAVORABLE OR UNFAVORABLE.
SENATOR WARNOCK, 50% FAVORABLE.
45% UNFAVORABLE.
HERSCHEL WALKER, YOU KNOW,
FOOTBALL HERO, UNIVERSITY OF
GEORGIA WENT ON TO PLAY IN THE
NFL, 39% FAVORABLE, 52%
UNFAVORABLE.
IT IS INTERESTING THAT THE
POLITICAL NEWCOMER HAS THE
HIGHER UNFAVORABLE RATING HERE.
HE'S BEING TREATED ALMOST LIKE
THE POLITICIAN OR IS IT JUST
BECAUSE THE TOLL OF THIS
CAMPAIGN PEOPLE HAVE MORE
DOUBTS.
>> I THINK HE'S RUN A PRETTY
DISASTROUS CAMPAIGN AND THAT IF
HE SOMEHOW EMERGES TO PREVAIL IN
THIS RUNOFF CONTEST THAT BRIAN
KEMP WILL IMMEDIATELY GO TO THE
TOP OF THE HEAP FOR GOP
PRESIDENTIAL CONTENDERS BECAUSE
IT WILL BE ALL GOVERNOR KEMP WHO
HAS HELPED PUSH HERSCHEL WALKER
FORWARD.
HE'S HAD A NUMBER OF PERSONAL
SCANDALS, CONTROVERSIES THAT
HAVE COME FORWARD AND ONE OF THE
MOST POPULAR ADS BY REVEREND
WARNOCK'S CAMPAIGN RIGHT NOW IS
JUST VOTERS WATCHING HERSCHEL
WALKER SAY GOOFY THINGS ON THE
STUMP THAT ARE KIND OF NON
SEQUITURS AND HIS TIES TO DONALD
TRUMP HAVE BEEN PROBLEMATIC IN
GEORGIA BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
POLLING, THAT VERY GOOD CNN CNN
POLLING YOU SEE HOW CLOSE THE
RACE IS ANY WAY WHICH IS WHY
THAT TURNOUT MATTERS AND, YOU
KNOW, WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT THE
GENERAL ELECTION RETURNS IS THAT
AROUND THE COUNTRY BLACK VOTERS
DID NOT COME OUT EN MASSE WITH
AS MUCH STRENGTH AS THEY DID IN
THE PREVIOUS ELECTION.
THERE ARE SIGNS THAT THAT IS
DIFFERENT IN THIS RUNOFF WHICH
IS REALLY INTERESTING.
TALK ABOUT THE YOUTH VOTERS, MAX
FROST, THE INCOMING 25-YEAR-OLD,
YOUNGEST EVER MEMBER OF CONGRESS
FROM FLORIDA WHO IS BLACK AND
HISPANIC IS GOING TO BE ONE OF
THE KIND OF POLITICAL
CELEBRITIES BROUGHT OUT OVER THE
WEEKEND TO TRY TO TURN OUT THE
YOUTH VOTE IN ATLANTA.
>> SO LET'S LOOK A LITTLE BEFORE
YOU JUMP IN TO CONTRAST IN THE
FINAL SECONDS.
THE WARNOCK ADS WERE PART OF
OBAMA'S MISSION, THAT HERSCHEL
WALKER IS NOT SERIOUS.
LISTEN.
>> SINCE THE LAST TIME I WAS
HERE, MR. WALKER HAS BEEN
TALKING ABOUT ISSUES THAT ARE OF
GREAT IMPORTANCE TO THE PEOPLE
OF GEORGIA.
LIKE WHETHER IT'S BETTER TO BE A
VAMPIRE OR A WEREWOLF.
IN CASE YOU'RE WONDERING, BY THE
WAY, MR. WALKER DECIDED HE
WANTED TO BE A WEREWOLF, WHICH
IS GREAT AS FAR AS I'M
CONCERNED.
HE CAN BE ANYTHING HE WANTS TO
BE EXCEPT FOR A UNITED STATES
SENATOR.
>> OBAMA TRYING TO JOIN THE
DEMOCRATIC EFFORT TO SAY WALKER
IS NOT UP TO THE JOB.
HE IS NOT SERIOUS.
WALKER, LISTEN TO THIS,
YESTERDAY UNDERSTANDING 200,000
PEOPLE VOTED FOR GOVERNOR KEMP'S
RE-ELECTION DID NOT VOTE FOR HIM
TRYING TO GET REPUBLICANS WHO
DON'T LIKE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
POLICIES BUT WHO ALSO DON'T LIKE
HIM TO COME OVER.
HERE HE IS ON VACCINE MANDATES.
>> 20,000, I'M GOING TO TELL YOU
IS ACTIVE DUTY WARRIORS IN THE
UNITED STATES MILITARY BEING
KICKED OUT BY JOE BIDEN AND
RAPHAEL WARNOCK FOR NOT TAKING
THAT COVID VASHOT.
YES.
AND THEN 40,000 ARE NATIONAL
GUARDSMEN BEING CUT OUT OF THEIR
MILITARY BENEFIT BY JOE BIDEN
AND RAPHAEL WARNOCK FOR NOT
TAKING THAT COVID SHOT.
I THINK THAT'S IMMORAL AND I
THINK IT'S TREASON.
>> YOU SEE HIM THERE TRYING TO
SCRATCH HIS WAY BACK INTO BEING
MORE OF A TRADITIONAL REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATE, WHICH IF PEOPLE
VIEWED HIM THAT WAY IN A STATE
LIKE GEORGIA HE WOULD HAVE A
BETTER SHOT.
>> AND YOU'RE SEEING HIM DO
SOMETHING THAT MANY MEMBERS OF
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY SAY WASN'T
DONE ENOUGH BY SOME CANDIDATES
LEADING UP TO THE MIDTERMS WHICH
IS ACTUALLY FOCUSING ON THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, NOT JUST
THE PREVIOUS PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION OR TRYING TO KIND OF
PLEDGE YOUR LOYALTY TO THE
FORMER PRESIDENT AS WELL.
RIGHT THERE HE'S ACTUALLY
FOCUSING ON SOME THINGS HE
THINKS CAN GALVANIZE SOME
REPUBLICAN VOTERS, BUT I THINK
IT'S ALSO INTERESTING YOU'RE
SEEING SOME OF THOSE STUMP FOR
DEMOCRATS, FOR SENATOR WARNOCK
AS WELL.
MORE OF MAKING THIS A VOICE
RATHER THAN A REFERENDUM.
NOT JUST EXPLAINING HOW THIS
COULD IMPACT CONGRESS BUT ALSO
SAYING, LOOK, JUST LOOK AT THE
COMMENTS OF THE OPPONENT HERE,
LOOK AT SOME OF THE GAFFES AND
THE CRISES, LOOK AT SOME OF THE
ACCUSATIONS AGAINST HIM, AS
WELL.
AND ALSO REMEMBER THAT WE'VE
BEEN HERE BEFORE IN TERMS OF A
RUNOFF ELECTION.
JUST ANOTHER NOTE ON THE EARLY
VOTING, THERE ARE SOME PROMINENT
DEMOCRATS THAT ARE PRETTY
EXCITED ABOUT SOME OF THOSE
NUMBERS.
YESTERDAY, LAST NIGHT, BEFORE
THE STATE DINNER, KEISHA LANCE
BOTTOMS AS WELL AS CHUCK SCHUMER
WENT ON TO TOUT SOME OF THE
TURNOUT.
WE'LL SEE HOW IT TURNS OUT.